todas las personas en este vídeo se
hicieron la prueba para el comí 19 antes
de la filmación cómo se siente cuando un
hombre te penetra puedes explicarlo de
forma que un hombre lo entienda o si él
le pedimos a nuestra audiencia que
enviara a sus preguntas sexuales más
íntimas vergonzosas y picantes para que
extraños las respondieran basándose en
sus experiencias
una educación sexual mujeres
heterosexuales tu primera vez dolió
recuerdo que fue una experiencia
agradable pero dolorosa y me sigue
doliendo por varios días después ya no
la verdad no me dolió fue muy cuidadoso
con eso y me preguntaba si me dolía o no
si no acostumbra va a tener algo en mi
vagina ni siquiera usaba tampones en ese
entonces ah no sangre ni nada por el
estilo fue genial
lo hicimos luego fuimos por burritos fue
agradable
parecería que hubiera más educación
emocional porque luego de mi primera vez
me tomo mucho tiempo para volver a besar
a alguien porque no me sentía del todo
cómoda porque esto era algo que había
reservado para alguien que fuese muy muy
especial por mucho mucho tiempo estaba
tratando de entender las citas y las
relaciones y no podía tener una relación
normal porque si un hombre venía a mí
incluso si todo se daba bien o si era
algo que yo quisiera de verdad se sentía
como algo malo
hoy cómo se siente cuando un hombre te
penetra puedes explicarlo de forma que
un hombre lo entienda los cielos es tan
extraño lo haré lo mejor que pueda para
un hombre cuando tú deberás necesitas ir
al baño
esa sensación de alivio pero es al revés
uno no lo siente en un solo lugar es
como yo lo sientes es como cuando le
pones una conga para algo esa sensación
de satisfacción cuando tapas una taza de
pepinillos si de verdad lo describía si
en alguna vez te has preocupado de que
tu página no se vea normal y así así he
sentido que no tengo una vagina normal
ya no si lo hice en algún punto porque
llegué a escuchar la retórica de que
parece un roast beef y pensaba mi vagina
así parece un roast beef pero no sé cuál
es el problema si tomas anticonceptivas
cómo afecta a tu cuerpo bueno
actualmente no las tomo pero cuando sí
lo hacía
ya que me ayudaría con el acné ya que
eso es algo que uno escucha
frecuentemente pero fue totalmente lo
opuesto lo empeoró afectó mi humor y
sentía que no era yo en realidad
juanes del día horrible que puede llegar
a tomar un tiempo encontrar las
pastillas que le funcionan a tu cuerpo
en mi caso am el asno varín y mi hermana
aprobó las no varíen aumentó 7 kilos y
la sodio lo principal es recordar
tomarlas porque yo suelo olvidar las
cosas y eso es lo que trae problemas y
con el implante sangre por casi un año
seguido y eso no fue divertido para nada
si tienes preguntas solo habla con tu
doctor sexo con el periodo como no todo
en mayúsculas nunca lo he tenido bueno
tuve el periodo por todo un año así que
es algo a lo que tuve que acostumbrarme
tenía que usar una toalla y condones
para ser honesta se siente mejor porque
las hormonas están por todas partes y es
como
no es tan tan malo como todos dicen que
es para mí tener sexo con el periodo es
algo incómodo por los numerosos
calambres y toda la vagina está
realmente sensible hay cosas como di
backups y otros productos para el sexo
con el periodo que van dentro de ti y
puedes tener más libertad así es como lo
publicitan sexo sin derrames el gees
normal masturbarse conozco personas que
dirían no no lo es y lo rechazan de
forma completa creo que hay personas que
dicen yo no me masturbo ni hago nada y
eso las carga creo que la masturbación
es la forma de liberarse lo hago casi
todos los días alguna vez te has
cuestionado sobre tu sexualidad y así a
través de una fase de cuestionamiento
como será que en algún punto me atraerá
a otra mujer creo que eso es algo normal
por lo que pasan las personas incluso
sabiendo de antemano que eres
heterosexual
una vez sentí una atracción muy fuerte
hacia una mujer pero creo que era más
una obsesión por cómo se veía y yo
quería ser como ella no estar con
alguna vez has tenido un orgasmo todavía
no sé si no cuando crecía está
especialmente en la pubertad que había
una especie de vergüenza sobre las
mujeres que se desarrollaban y se
excitaban si algo te excitaba era como
no no esto no es normal si algo me
excitaba solo me sentaba y no hacía nada
al respecto hasta que se me quitara y es
por eso que luego mi cuerpo cuando se
trata del orgasmo se cierra y es como no
no pasa está esa es mi mi mente
bloqueando me y trabajo en eso
si alguna vez has fingido un orgasmo
una vez cuando era joven
porque me sentía mal pero nunca más
sentía vergüenza porque estaba tardando
mucho y uno tiene la expectativa de
actuar como las mujeres en las porno
es importante encontrar un hombre que te
haga llegar al orgasmo y si no te hacen
llegar al orgasmo la primera vez creo
que deberías buscar a una pareja que
esté dispuesta a aprender y ajustarse a
lo que te gusta para que ambos puedan
disfrutar se aprenden lo que te gusta es
una buena pareja para ti y una con quien
disfrutaras el sexo por mucho tiempo
estuve con parejas que por cinco o seis
años cuando tenía sexo una y otra vez
nunca tuve un orgasmo pero yo tampoco
sabía cómo tener un orgasmo no me
masturbaba no me comunicaba con mi
pareja no sabía que posiciones me
gustaban tuvimos que tener una
conversación porque era esto es mentira
me miento a mí te miento a ti y todo
esto podría ser mucho mejor y recuerdo
que él estaba acostado en la cama y
cuando hablamos de esto y él me decía oh
por dios lo siento así que no es tan
necesario estar con una pareja
que llegue al orgasmo pero si es
importante para mí tener una pareja que
ponga en primer lugar mi placer sientes
que la mayoría del tiempo con plazas a
los hombres y lo que ellos quieren yo a
veces me pongo no nerviosa en el sentido
de estar y haciéndolo bien realmente le
gusta al principio sí pero cuando
comencé a
y estar con más personas me di cuenta
que comencé a preguntar qué quieres que
te haga qué te gusta y me quedaba que me
gusta a mí eso no lo sé
pues se considera abuso o violaciones
creo que me ha pasado pero no estoy
segura de eso
no
y sé que a muchas personas les dicen que
la violación es esta cosa grande
aterradora y agresiva puede ser por algo
web o por alguien con quien te sentías
cómoda o con alguien que creías de
confianza está bien si hablo de un abuso
es que en mi primera vez fue una
situación un poco forzada en algún punto
si quería hacerlo con esa persona pero
yo no sentía que estaba lista en sí y
fui presionada para hacerlo y eso fue
algo en realidad no nos enseñan de
coerción ni cosas así en la escuela ni
cómo funciona el consentimiento así que
no entendía totalmente que si ya había
dicho que si eventualmente podía cambiar
de opinión y eso está eso no está bien
muchas de nosotras nos preguntamos esto
he tenido conversaciones muy personales
con amigas las cuales no se habían dado
cuenta de que habían sido abusadas o
violadas sino hasta años después
si puedes costear los y tu seguro lo
paga busca ayuda y asesoramiento
profesional porque es un tema del cual
se necesita que se hable mucho más una
última pregunta qué cosa te hubiera
gustado aprender sobre la educación
sexual que las mujeres se masturban el
rango de consentimiento y como decir que
no ofrece haría que enseñaran más si el
sexo no tiene que ser algo vergonzoso
para las mujeres
educación sexual síguenos en instagram
jubilee media para enviar preguntas a
los próximos episodios
gracias por ver
[Música]
jubilee juntos por la empatía